vous vous êtes dit en faveur d'une
enquête après les audiences du comité
parlementaire cette semaine est-ce que
vous êtes encore du même avis qu'il faut
une enquête publique
absolument je pense que c'est presque
injuste que demander au parlementaires
de se pencher sur cette question ça
affecte directement la façon qu'ils sont
élus la façon que les obtiennent leur
nomination en plus de ça c'est pas
seulement la question de l'ingérence
étrangère et aussi la question de la loi
sur les élections et toute une série de
choses pour pouvoir prendre ceci au
sérieux ça va prendre du temps et les
comités parlementaires n'ont pas souvent
le temps de le faire alors je pense que
une commission publique qui serait pas
totalement public mais on aimerait
probablement un juge avec une certaine
crédibilité ça nous aiderait à
comprendre un peu plus qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
que si on est limité à une commission
parlementaire vous le dites bien
pas public parce qu'on s'en doute il y a
nécessairement des renseignements qui
peuvent pas être dévoilés publiquement
des enjeux de sécurité nationale mais en
comité parlementaire justement
revenons-y à la conseillère du Premier
ministre en sécurité nationale qui
suggérait qu'une enquête publique
permettrait pas d'aller plus loin parce
que ce serait pas possible de parler
publiquement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
je pense que Madame Tarma a raison par
contre il y a une tradition Canada il y
a des précédents au Canada qui
permettent au gouvernement fédéral de
créer des commissions d'enquête qui
peuvent recevoir des informations
classées alors l'idée serait que le
commissaire ou les commissaires ils sont
personnels pourraient recevoir ce genre
d'information il pourrait les prendre en
ligne de compte et expliquer dans le
rapport public qu'est-ce qu'ils ont vu
et pourquoi ils ont ils ont envie à des
conclusions alors les commissions
parlementaires ne peuvent vraiment pas
recevoir ce genre d'information alors je
pense que la clé c'est de créer une
commission avec un commissaire avec une
grande crédibilité qui est totalement
non partisan chose difficile à trouver
dans le contexte parlementaire vous en
2010 monsieur fadon lorsque vous étiez à
la tête du SARS je vous y entendu en
entrevue dire que des élus canadiens
étaient sous l'influence étrangère
notamment sous l'influence chinoise donc
moi ça m'a amené à deux réflexions
premièrement parfois c'est possible de
parler même quand on est le directeur du
SARS mais aussi ça me donne l'impression
que ça fait longtemps qu'on parle de ce
problème là non
oui je pense que c'est d'être le sars
était au courant depuis 2010 et même
peut-être un peu avant qu'est-ce qui est
changé je pense que c'est un peu deux
choses la tissu de la chaîne est un peu
plus proactive et un peu plus agressive
avec l'avenue du président j à la
présidente de la Chine notre politique
étrangère de sécurité de défense et
beaucoup plus proactive
alors ça c'est un élément l'autre
élément c'est que je pense que les
ingérences chinoises ont lieu un peu
partout maintenant en Occident on met
ceci ensemble oui on était au courant
mais on n'était pas aussi préoccupé
parce qu'ils étaient sous un certain
seuil d'inquiétude mais elle prend
quelle forme maintenant cette ingérence
étrangère selon vous selon vos
informations
mais je pense qu'on en parle beaucoup
dans les médias ces temps-ci on utilise
les réseaux sociaux pour faire écouter
les gens des des informations
incorrectes mais c'est essentiellement
de l'argent de l'information des gens
l'argent la loi au Canada est très
stricte on ne peut pas donner des sous
pour les élections pour appuyer un
député un candidat au-delà de certaines
limites si des agents de la Chine
donnent des argent à des candidats ça
leur donne un grand avantage
deuxièmement l'utilisation de
d'individus des agents de la chaîne pour
participer à des démonstrations pour
faire le tour des des comtés et
troisièmement c'est surtout
l'utilisation des informations
incorrectes dans les réseaux sociaux
avec le passage du temps devient des
gens viennent à croire ce genre de
choses là et ça peut influencer leur
vote de l'argent de l'information et des
gens je trouve que c'est bien synthétisé
on en a entendu parler comme vous le
disiez dans les journaux grâce à des
fuites vous en tant qu'ensien patron du
SCRS
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire que comment
vous expliquer ces fuites là qu'est-ce
qui fait que des fuites peuvent comme ça
arriver dans la sphère publique
mais pour commencer je pense que c'est
pas une bonne idée les secrets de l'État
doivent rester les secrets de l'État
la seule raison que qui me vient l'idée
c'est que des gens sont terriblement
frustrés ils ont des informations qui
touchent ce genre d'ingérence et le
gouvernement c'est pas que le
gouvernement n'a rien fait mais le
gouvernement a pas fait beaucoup pour
contrer ce genre d'ingérence et en bout
de ligne si ce n'était des des fuites on
ne se parlerait pas cet après-midi
mais en même temps vous dites c'est pas
une bonne idée mais ça permet d'en
parler et là il y a le sars qui veut
mener une enquête c'est un peu normal de
savoir où d'où proviennent les fuites
surtout pour essayer de les stopper
j'imagine mais est-ce qu'il y a un
risque le sars finalement investisse
davantage d'énergie à trouver les
origines de la fuite qu'à se préoccuper
de la gérance chinoise
non je ne pense pas que c'est aussi
facile que ça mais ils vont sans doute
essayer de découvrir probablement avec
le gendarmerie royale d'où viennent les
fuites mais en bout de ligne je pense
que leur préoccupation c'est vraiment
d'ingérence étrangères probablement ont
causé les fuites
en terminant monsieur fadon bon on l'a
entendu là en entrée de jeu juste un
Trudeau qui refuse de déclencher une
enquête à votre avis pourquoi il refuse
comme ça les demandes des parties
d'opposition votre demande aussi il y a
son ancien conseiller Jérôme boat qui
disait qu'une enquête publique serait
peut-être une bonne idée pourquoi il
refuse c'est demande là répéter
maintenant
dans mon expérience avec mon expérience
d'une carte décennie comme fonctionnaire
fédéral j'ai rarement vu un ministre ou
un premier ministre dit que j'aimerais
vraiment une enquête publique et la
raison principale que l'instant qu'on a
une
enquête publique le gouvernement perd
totalement contrôle on a un juge et puis
va aller où il veut aller il y a des
exceptions des grandes commissions
royales comme sur l'économie canadienne
ou le bilingus c'est dans une autre
catégorie mais pour les choses comme
l'ingérence étrangère l'instant que le
commissaire est nommé le gouvernement
perd tout contrôle
et on se rappelle peut-être de la
Commission
de Monsieur chrétien c'était
probablement pas son intention que
Monsieur Camry aille ou Italie il y a
toujours un risque quand on nomme une
commission publique que on perd le
contrôle au point où on aurait voulu pas
nommer la commission d'enquête alors on
verra si votre tenir bon ou non Richard
fadon je rappelle que vous êtes l'ancien
directeur du Service canadien du
renseignement de sécurité merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
au revoir